Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa!
I'm...
Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Good Morning!
Thank you Ruffians for waking up bright and early and joining us today for our 84th episode!
Bye bye!
BAU BAU!
Wow, thank you for being here.
Ha!
What?
I write that!
Thank you for being here, Ruffians.
Wow, for Ruffians that are maybe joining us for the first time today, you're able to get up better maybe, you know.
Good job.
Well, to explain FUWAMOCO Morning, it's a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
Well Moco-chan, it's a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
What's today have in store for us?
My trouble.
Trouble?!
My trouble!
What kind of trouble?
Pero trouble.
There's been a Pero Sighting.
Again.
Okay, let's have a look then.
Say then... Oh!
Ah!
Oh!
Oh, look!
Pero's just sitting there!
Yeah, he found a good spot where he can sit comfortably and nicely.
That's pretty nice.
Cool, yeah.
What do you think he's doing, the Ruffians?
Nesting.
I don't know, maybe he beat some squirrels up and overtook their whole base.
Maybe you just got a little too close to him!
And that's why he's giving you the luckiest.
Laying eggs?
Well, you know, I was thinking with spring coming up and everything, I like to think that, you know, maybe he's going to sprout and become a new part to the tree!
You know, like, new growth.
That's nice.
Yeah.
Do you think he'd be beautiful or terrifying?
Maybe he'd bear fruits or blossom with a bunch of pretty flowers?
Ruffians!
G-g-g-grafting?
What?
Beautiful tree!
Terrifying.
Yeah.
This is terrifying.
I guess, yeah.
Yeah.
I don't think Pero's gonna grow into a new part of the tree, huh?
After all, he's Pero!
A demon dog, you know?
Yeah.
I can't do stuff like that.
If there's a Pero tree, then there's a FUWAMOCO tree.
We're Demon Dogs!
BAU BAU!
I don't want to become a tree.
Be careful, okay?
You never know when some scary faces are on trees.
I'm not a tree!
I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not a tree, I'm Mococo.
BAU BAU!
Mighty Fuwamo!
I'm Fuwawa.
What?
Well, Ruffians!
I know we like to say thank you lots, but is it okay if we say thank you more?
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
Because you know, our newest song cover of Let Me Be With You from the Anime Children's has now over 200,000 views on YouTube!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
We're really happy!
Thank you Ruffians!
We love seeing all your comments too!
I know!
It seems like we're able to awaken a lot of hidden memories within you.
Maybe remind you of a simpler time!
Simpler time since we watched Chobits for the first time.
Right!
But it makes us really happy, you know?
We hope that you'll continue to listen to our cover lots and lots and that maybe we can help soothe you during your busy days.
You know?
Nostalgic.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians.
You know, all of a sudden, we're nearing the end of this month.
We're here already, huh?
Almost March!
That's pretty weird.
Do you remember what happened at the beginning of this month, Ruffians?
I know I tried to remember.
Right?
That's right!
Our birthdays!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for being there for our big birthday celebration!
As you might know, we also released special birthday merch!
And it's currently on pre-orders!
Yeah, still on pre-orders.
Mococo-san!
There's also Fuwawa-san!
I don't know about them.
They're separate!
Not that.
They're pretty matching too!
Fuwawa-san.
Yes, yes, yes!
Fuwawa-san!
The note that is also still on pre-order so you can get it right now.
But, what we would like you to focus on is our birthday song.
But, but, but, but.
Look, can you find it?
There's the super cute Ruffian questions too!
So Ruffians, if you're interested in grabbing your own too, welcome to your home with Ruffians.
I really recommend that you do so soon because the period window for our birthday merch is going to be ending on March 3rd PT.
March 3rd, okay.
Yeah, before you know it, you're not going to be able to get them.
It's really, really soon.
So please don't forget Ruffians, okay?
We also need to remember to get a few more Ruffians for ourselves too, huh?
Don't forget, Moco-chan.
But also, a big, big thank you to all the Ruffians who have already ordered their birthday merch too.
Thank you so much to Aizen.
We really can't wait for you to receive them in the upcoming months too.
We're looking forward to your photos, okay?
Please take lots, okay?
BAU BAU!
I've been so happy because there's a lot of Ruffians receiving them.
The debut is now!
I'm so excited!
Posting photos, okay!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
It's the morning!
It's FUWAMOCO Morning!
Have you had breakfast yet?
Have you?
What are you eating?
I want to know.
This is a good question.
Why?
Why
Panola and milk, yum!
Eggs and ham, nice.
Overnight oats, good.
Yum, sure.
Brown sugar bagel, ooh, cute.
Hashbrowns!
Well, kind of on that topic yesterday, Ruffians.
We had a wonderful morning spent having a brunch together, all together with Advent, the Advent Tracks.
It was fun!
It was really fun!
You know... What did we talk about, Moco-chan?
A bunch of silly things, you know?
Like, what we would be if we were a food condiment?
Yeah!
I was surprised that everybody liked talking about that so much, because... I don't know, I thought that was only the topics that I like to think about.
So, I was happy.
You know how much we all really love hash browns.
Hash browns!
hololive hash browns.
You know our dislike for cheese.
Diamond Dogs dislike cheese.
And pillows and our sleeping preferences.
You know typical Advent stuff.
Yeah!
Right!
It was very fun though.
Yeah!
Right, Ruffians?
Huh?
What?
What do you mean, Ruffians?
It was just good happy times.
Yeah.
No misunderstandings.
No.
Nothing weird.
Yeah.
It's a very fun talk.
Thank you.
Very fun talk, right?
That was really fun.
A good, a good chill vibe!
Yeah!
You know, but I really hope that we can share more meals all together in the future!
Did you like it?
Ruffians!
I was a little embarrassed eating in front of everybody, but...
But you know, instead of just sharing meals in the future, I'd really like if everyone could all cook our best dishes for each other and share them.
Right?
I wanna try Biboo's fried rice.
I actually really do too.
I'm curious.
Yeah.
Biboo's Fried Rice sounds like a really, really good recipe, right?
It does!
It's a good name, huh?
Right!
Or a collab.
Maybe one day, huh?
Because we should call it Little Biboo's Fried Rice.
Little Biboo!
Why?
I don't know, it has more of a I-gotta-have-this kind of feeling.
The Little Biboo's Fried Rice.
Right!
Huh?
One day, huh?
One day!
Biboo's karaage too?
It's a full meal.
Right.
I don't know what I'm gonna make because it's all kind of average.
Huh, Moco-chan?
It's all good.
BAU BAU!
You want food?
Well, it's time for breakfast!
Go have food!
If you feel hungry, go have food.
Did I make you hungry?
You better go eat then.
That was our plan all along!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians.
It's all my fault.
Because, well, uh... Well, you know how Moco-chan and I, we worked so hard at everything.
Because, well, you know, there was the... The update.
You know when we were really really lucky to be able to play the new Suica game update with you the other day right after it just came out and everything.
Yeah, we worked hard as we could.
Well... When we were playing, I maybe got a bit carried away.
And...
It's not really my fault though.
It's SuikaGames' fault for making the two-player DLC so intense.
You know, we were able to play the new 2-player DLC together.
And they had a bunch of fun new mods.
It was fun.
Not just like the original mod, that would be pretty great.
But they also had the attack mod and the time-based mod too.
They were good.
They were all really fun.
I might have gotten a bit serious about it too.
After all, we are seriously silly.
And, well, maybe I wasn't doing as great as I had hoped.
And I kind of got pretty worked up.
And I may have made a sound that sounded similar to a cat's hiss.
But!
It's not my fault, okay?
It's the game's fault, and Moco-chan's fault!
Why is it my fault?
Huh?
No, Moco-chan.
But, well, I guess Ruffians, what I wanted to say...
Is that I'm sorry that I got caught up and I made a sound that could be interpreted as a hiss.
I'm a demon dog.
I'm not a cat.
You know this, right?
Yeah.
I'll make sure you know that I don't make any more mistakes like this in the future, okay, Ruffians?
You promise?
BAU BAU.
Next time I'm gonna beat you.
No you won't!
BAU BAU!
Let's play more Suika games!
I'll win again.
Nope!
BAU BAU!
Actually, today, we have something a bit special today.
Moco-chan.
Well, it's not that day of the week, but... Is it okay?
Is it?
You know, we thought it might be nice, so...
Yeah!
Okay!
Ruffians!
Today is a special day!
For the first time ever!
Well, it's time for our FUWAMOCO Fun Talk!
And you're going to hear it straight from us, FUWAMOCO!
Ruffians!
Hello!
Good job with everything recently!
Even working hard!
And look!
You know, we're almost through winter!
Blossoms are beginning to bloom on the trees!
You know, slowly but surely, it's getting a bit brighter outside!
And you know what spring means!
It means a new start!
New challenges!
Everything is fresh.
At times, you know, it can be a bit scary.
But change can be very exciting too.
Change can mean that you get closer to the things you feel very passionate about.
Closer to your burning dreams.
It can also bring new scary mountains and some deep valleys as well.
But... You're strong!
Yeah!
You're strong!
You know, even if it takes you a little longer, you can overcome them all, okay?
Yeah.
You're resilient!
So don't be scared of change and challenge yourself.
And even if maybe things don't go exactly as you imagined, you'll end somewhere new and filled with possibilities.
More importantly, please remember that when everything is overwhelming and you're not too sure how things are going to go, tell yourself that everything will work out in the end.
It'll be okay!
It will!
I believe in you!
I believe in you too!
You can do this!
We all can!
We can do it!
Ganbatte deshita!
BAU BAU!
We can do it, Ruffians!
You can do it!
Well, Ruffians, we also have something else we'd like to share today.
Wow, you know that
We gave you a heads up a few weeks ago, but this next upcoming week, we won't be putting out a streaming schedule.
Yeah, you remember, right?
It's a bit scary.
The first time there hasn't been a schedule for us since debut, right?
We wanted to let you know, Ruffians, that this also means that there will be a bit of a temporary break for FUWAMOCO Morning.
We'll be right back to it, okay?
But for now, FUWAMOCO Morning will be on a bit of a break.
It just can't be helped.
Can't be helped.
But we hope that you'll be waiting with anticipation for FUWAMOCO Morning's return when it comes back though.
Don't wait!
No way, okay!
Why is the first comment, I see, DOOM?
Ruffians!
You're being silly.
We just want to keep you on a loop is all, too.
You don't have to worry, you don't have to panic, okay?
It's not that big of a deal, Ruffians.
Like we mentioned, you know, Ruffians, we feel so incredibly lucky to be a part of your life, to be a part of your morning, you know?
You know, three times a week with FUWAMOCO Morning.
So we're really looking forward to more time, more mornings, more FUWAMOCO Mornings together.
Okay.
We don't want you to panic.
We just, you know, it's your schedule too.
Yeah.
So we want to keep you in the loop.
This doesn't mean that you can sleep in the whole office.
No, it doesn't, okay?
Yeah, no bad habits forming, okay?
No, no.
Okay.
We just wanted to let you know.
Because maybe there's some ruffians that didn't quite put everything together there.
The no schedule.
And then going to Gorilla Streams.
So we just wanted to let you know, okay?
BAU BAU!
B
You know, Omi is a happy older puppy who adores Coraline.
I can tell!
That is a very big smile.
But actually, he doesn't know it yet, but he's on the way to the vet.
Oops.
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
Yeah.
It'll be okay, Ruffians.
It'll be okay.
Yeah.
He's having fun.
He doesn't know yet, but... He doesn't know.
He's in for a surprise.
Yeah.
Well, how does only BAU BAU?
Maybe sort of...
BAU BAU!
Oh!
Maybe, you know, on the drive we get some Puppuccino.
Always, always, I want a Puppuccino!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU PUPPUCCINO!
It's just like that.
Exactly!
Very exciting.
Right?
Well, you know, Omi is the best doggo you could ever wish for.
You know, he's chill, he loves to go for rides with you, and Age won't stop his fashion sense.
Yeah, so even if you're taking him to the vet, he'll just sit there and smile because that means that he gets to go for another ride together with you.
Such a wonderful, wonderful day.
Even if you know that means he's gonna end up with a bat.
It's okay.
Yeah.
It's good.
BAU BAU!
Right?
Omi's adorable.
Thank you.
And for today, I went on a walk.
We have De-den!
Ms.
Donuts?
Huh?
Ms.
Donuts?
Mister Donuts?
Ms.
Donuts.
It's like Perroccino and Peroncina!
I guess it could happen.
Ruffians, this is shocking news!
Miss Donut, it's too bad that they didn't sub on the rings, but we're glad that you still had a good walk during your month's break.
Maybe you got a nice snack too.
Thank you Miss Donut for the nice snack.
BAU BAU!
And for the question of the day, we have the dance!
Konnichiwa, FUWAMOCO-chan!
Konnichiwa!
I watched a video about how different it feels to talk in English and Japanese.
Do you notice a difference in how you talk and feel when speaking in English or Japanese?
Do you sometimes mix the language or talk in Japanese or English secretly to each other in public?
I think, you know, it really is very different for us, you know, the differences between speaking English versus Japanese.
I feel like this probably goes with each language, but you can express different sides of yourself with like different languages, you know.
It's a little bit strange, but I think it's cool too.
I think if you're bilingual, you'll probably understand a bit right.
I feel like, you know, we have a lot to say in English.
We also have a lot to say in Japanese, too!
Yeah!
Yeah, I think we can be pretty silly in Japanese.
There's things that we can say in Japanese that we want to say, but we can't really say in English.
Yeah.
You know, it's just that each language has its own strength.
Not that one is particularly right or wrong.
It's different, you know, right?
Yeah.
Have you noticed this?
Maybe that...
We have lots of fun in both languages.
As for mixing them though...
Moco-chan understands Japanese.
Moco-chan understands English.
So, does it really matter?
We're always together, you know?
So, even if it's a mix of everything, we can understand each other.
So, you know, we don't have any issues there.
It's sort of silly.
Even if we don't use words, we still understand each other.
Is that English even that important in the end?
Understandable.
Thank you so much, Moco, for all your submissions of FUWAMOCO Morning.
We'll continue to look on out for that.
So please make sure you keep on sending your walks, your doggy of the days, your questions!
Okay, even while FUWAMOCO Morning's on, a little bit of a break.
Even more so.
Yeah, even more so, right?
Okay, Ruffians!
Don't forget now, okay?
BAU BAU!
Well, for our next team, we have... De-den!
Tonight we're gonna be playing Suspicious Person Information.
I don't know what to expect!
I wonder who the suspicious person's gonna be, huh?
Not us.
Yeah.
Fuwawa Chihokuzu!
Fushi- Nope!
Nope!
Chigau yo!
I'm not!
No, that's somebody else.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
And if we take another look at our schedule, this weekend we have our big Rock n' Rawr party!
Wait, that's tomorrow.
Tomorrow Ruffians!
We're gonna have so much fun!
And then it's time for us to share our big announcement with you!
We really hope that you'll join us.
It's very exciting.
Not today!
Tomorrow!
Please be there!
It's gonna be a big party, okay?
The rockin'est, rollin'est party!
That's for sure!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much Ruffians for joining us!
Today for FUWAMOCO Morning, as well as all the FUWAMOCO Mornings before today's episode, all of the previous ones, whether it was Episode 1, Episode 26, Episode 32, or today, Episode 84.
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Mostly safe!
BAU BAU!
Bermuda!
Eguizabue!
BAU BAU!
Tenta!
Asante Star!
BAU BAU!
Infernos!
Ace!
BAU BAU!
Ludang!
Dustin King!
BAU BAU!
Belphegor!
To every other ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!